the first thing I'd like to say is that
I heard through the grapevine that a one
cat got a little older ride a cat yeah
well I'd like to I'd like to know a
little happy birthday 23 25 25 I don't
remember that what's it like young it's
great I still don't really have any
bodily aches yeah yeah never tell you
what else is there a percent about when
I said he asked me about my childhood
and I was like I was like well I mean I
you know I moved every I was moved every
truck in two years to a different
country and when I was 14 I was sent to
boarding school I my family was in Saudi
Arabia I was sent to boarding school for
four years and the therapist goes like
this he goes like this he goes um they
threw you away cry no they didn't had to
resign the other day because while he
was on a zoom meeting he was afraid that
he wasn't gonna have enough time to take
a shower and then go run his errands
shortly after so he decided to minimize
the zoom meeting which he thought would
shut off his camera but did uh and he
took a shower he brought his laptop into
the shower with him so he could still
talk and be a part of the meeting while
he took a shower and very quickly a
bunch of people realized what was
happening he had a lot of colleagues
tried to call
give him a heads up people in the
meeting or kind of look around like
someone gonna tell him it's not good let
him know that he didn't exit it out and
he ended up yeah there's I think a
couple photos going around so he made a
mistake because he deserved to lose his
job if I don't shower no he didn't get
fired he chose to resign himself why why
I'm sorry I don't know exactly why he
chose to resign I think he it's
something along the lines of he thought
it was a bad look for the office if he
stayed somebody said that to him that's
what he was forced into resignation
autumn the bottom corner right here it's
already blurred out but you can see have
to resign for god sakes no I mean you
know you could be in better shape but
[ __ ] what's going on he ended up saying
that he was not embarrassed by being
nude or anyone seeing him nude and
that's why where there was a woman who
called the police on a bird watcher and
she ended up having like her dog taken
away cuz he asked her to have her dog on
a leash do you guys remember this yeah
she's really gotten beat up over this
yeah so what's happening is Manhattan is
trying to proceed and press charges
against this woman for her hate crime
and the man
Christian Cooper is actually not
cooperating with the police because he
says that he thinks the public lynching
that's happening or on her end is
punishment so he doesn't want to
actually help with the office pressing
charges this is a good man this is a
reasonable man this is a real man and
this is this is a who most of America is
black white whatever I appreciate a guy
like that whose guy look the girl is
[ __ ] crazy probably having a moment
she's not like that all the time maybe
she is but does it matter since it
[ __ ] weirdo or she's not now or she
was in that moment you know and he's
like I'm a what this is a we're like
he's not gonna be part of a political
lynching explosive I mean I've never
loved her job she's like what the hell's
what else you want to do with somebody
like this and you end and she's been
blasted everywhere which which you know
which means you're you're done because
you had who knows maybe she's hysterical
maybe she has terrible fear and anxiety
maybe she's not right mentally we don't
know right nobody knows who loves to
just destroy you know there was it there
was a really using thing about how all
these intellectuals from governments
with Marsalis no Chomsky you know
writers and artists intellectuals sign
this whole thing about how they're
against canceled culture how basically
they are for free speech the free-flow
exchange of ideas we should all be able
to express ourselves even if they're not
popular lets happen that they it's just
America and all of those people suddenly
were like like this this box writer
who's a trans woman she she wanted her
colleagues signed it and she was an icon
she on public blast on public glass
tooth I don't want to be fired or even
recommend I just don't feel safe with
him there Simon say anything to JK
Rowling's sign because JK Rowling said
that woman is a
and so I don't feel safe oh yeah baby
but but but it was retweeted thirteen
thousand times so you don't want them to
be you don't have me what you don't have
to cancel so so the people that signed
this thing that was just for free speech
are now being attacked and some of the
people that sided like I had no idea
that JK Rowling's sided I'm so sorry
you [ __ ] you little [ __ ] sign the
[ __ ] thing it's just about free
speech the free flow exchange of ideas
so I'm gonna talk more on this
eventually right now it's a funny time
you see my back ripple and I pull myself
up like a champ like a champ through 30
times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a guess and it's a
gift
it's a gift